his saffron robe disappears beneath the
white of his medical protection suit as
maha promphong prepares to head out the
buddhist monk leads a volunteer team
organized by his bangkok temple to one
of the many poor communities suffering
from thailand's worst covet 19 outbreak
since the start of the pandemic
when it comes to taking care of patients
and access to basic public health this
is something that should have been taken
care of by the government we all know
the kovit 19 situation in thailand is
very severe not everyone has had their
inoculations many people have fallen
through the cracks and have not received
any help
his team administers rapid tests for
those who can't afford them two lines
means positive
in this cramped household six of the 12
people tested positive for covet 19.
but it's not just those being neglected
by the government's covid19 medical
response plan who are suffering
the economic impact on some of
thailand's industries is so deep they
are turning to the courts to hold the
government accountable
spas and massage parlors are big
business in thailand at least they were
before the pandemic the industry used to
bring in over a billion dollars a year
but now more than 80 percent of the
businesses are closed for good putting
more than two hundred thousand people
out of work
in the repeated times the government has
tightened covet 19 restrictions spas and
massage parlors topped the list of
closures they've been closed for most of
the year without any compensation from
the government a group of massage parlor
owners and masseuses filed a class
action suit in civil court seeking six
million dollars in compensation
this case is where many victims have
been damaged by similar actions and the
people damaged by these actions of the
government should be compensated at the
same time this is so they don't have to
risk filing individual suits and
possibly getting different verdicts
the prime minister's office and the
ministry of public health both refused
our interview requests
as the government tries to keep up with
its delayed vaccine program new
infections will continue to increase and
the lockdown will likely remain as will
the reliance on volunteers to come to
the aid of the communities that need the
most help scott heidler al jazeera
bangkok